يطبطب علي باقابل اللي بيشتمني بقابل واحد
ممكن يكون راكب جنبي يقعد يتريق يقعد يهزر
عنده حاله يعني اللي قاعد عنده حاله دهون
طب انت هتموتينا طب انت انت اللي هتسوقي
بجد طب انت اللي هتطلعي منها انت بتعرفي
تسوقي انا ساعات بيفتح العربيه لاقيني
واحده ست بعياله ينزل من العربيه لا لا
انزلي دي هتموتنا مش عارفه ايه والكلام ده
ابل
[موسيقى]
اسمي رانيا القاضي
باعتبر نفسي سفيره شغاله في شركه طيران
مسافر كل واحد خدام اكل عيشه شغاله اخذته
مقطع من السيده عائشه اول بنت سواقت
ميكروباز معي رخصه اولى الصوره معي الحمد
لله بانزل الحمل عادي ممكن الواحد فعلا
يقول لي انت بتحملي ايه هو انت ما تستاهلي
دول يا ست انت ما بيعجبنيش الكلام ده حمل
برده ولو ما اخذتش حق همم باعرف اجيب حقي
ازاي بالادب والاحترام عايز يشتغل عندي
عيال ملزومه في رقبتي عندي
ايجار عندي قشطه عربيتي همم برده مديونه
برده بس برده محمود على ربنا
بجد
[موسيقى]
اقعد شويه اتكل على الله ادور
عربيتك على الله عيالي بقى ممكن يصحوا
الساعه 10:00 يتصل بيا يا ماما
[موسيقى]
ايه فعلا في اولها لقيت ناس بتحاربني جامد
قوي مش عايزين نشتغل مش عايزني اكل عيش مش
عايزين يديني الدفع لا عايزين نبقى منكسره
كده مذلوله لا بس يكون عندك اراده يكون
عندك هم كده انك
كويسه
ممكن يكون راكب جنبي يقعد يتريق يقعد يهزر
يعني اللي قاعد عنده حاله ظهور طب انت
هتموتينا طب انت انت بجد
زبون بيفتح العربيه
[موسيقى]
ممكن الاقي واحد بيشرب سيجاره يقول لي خذي
سيجاره قولي لا مش عايزه عندي عندي اراده
طب خذي اقول له لا ما حدش يصدق ان انا ما
باشربش شاي وما باشربش قهوه وما باشربش
ناس كافيه ما باشربش هو انا عشان خاطر
سواقت ميكروباص يبقى انا يبقى انا
قليله ادب لا جديره باكله عيشي جديره
بشغلي ما باعملش حاجه تغضب ربنا افتكري
كده لما ظابط يعدي او يشوفني يقول لي ازيك
يا استاذ رانيا ازيك يا اسطى رانيا الحمد
لله يعني سيتي وسمعتي مسمعه اه ممكن الناس
تقول لك بس دي قاعده مع الرجاله همم دي
كلامها على الرجاله هي الظروف اتحطتني
بكده ان انا لازم اقعد مع رجاله مش هاجيب
واحده ست مكانيكيه ولا ست همم كهربائيه
ولا ست تزقني انا ممكن الغيار بتاع
العربيه ده يقع مني مش هيقول واحده ست
والنبي اقعدي دواسه ونعمل لي تحت عشان
ترموا لي المسمار ده ممكن الاقي شاب اقول
له لو سمحت ممكن يقول لي حاضر
دي الاسطى رانيا اولا يا اخت لينا زبونه
ورشه يعني دي ورشتها اللي في العربيه
ولازم بيتعمل بتتقدر نسبين عشان هي واحده
ست ما ينفعش تقف في وسط مثلا كم رجل بتيجي
ليها الاولويه سنه ممكن بعمل لها عربيتها
الاول ومشيها وهي بتجيء ما بتتاخرش باقول
لها قد كده بتقول لي تفضل شكرا يا اسطى
شعبان الله يبارك لك على اللي انت بتعمله
معايا
بس الحمد لله الحمد لله بقى لي 22 سنه معي
رخصه اولى الريس قال لك ايه اللي مش
هيشتغل مش هياكل فعلا الشباب كلها معها
تعليم وقاعده على القهوه البنات كلها معها
تعليم وقاعده هنا وهنا ليه انزلي حفري مع
الناس الحفري مع اكل عيشك هتنتهي صح الصح
والغلط غلط غلط لو انا ما اشتغلتش باعمل
غلط انا باشتغل عشان خاطر اللي ورائي
باشتغل لان انا ما قلتش حد الدين دلوقت
يقول يا رانيا انا معيش اجره همم اركب
اقول له اركب يا ابني انا عندي زيك اركب
يا حبيبي الدنيا لسه بخير والله العظيم
الدنيا لسه بخير كل اسبوع عايزه تركب معي
علميني السواقه اقول لها انا متطلقه الاول
باقول لاي ست محترمه متربيه على طبليه
امها او ابوها عندها مبدا ان تعرف تجيب
الجنيه وتشتغلي اشتغلي في بيتك مش عيب
انزلي اشتغلي في الشارع وعلى الرصيف اللي
عايزهك تحمي نفسها بتحمي نفسها مش لازم
تكون بنت مين ساكراني العربيه دي سطراني
[موسيقى]